hello there I'm Greg Sadler and this is
number six in the series of videos that
I'm creating in order to help what we
call lifelong learners or people
carrying out self-directed study in the
area of philosophy in these videos I
give you a bit of background and advice
about important philosophical thinkers
and authors or about movements that that
contains sometimes multiple authors and
the one that I'm doing today is our
first jump into medieval philosophy the
first five are all on thinkers or
schools in ancient philosophy and I
thought it would be nice to do a little
bit of medieval starting with somebody
who I have been working on now for about
twenty years and who I really like I
teach in my classes I've done a lot of
publication and presentations on that
and that is Anselm of Canterbury so
we're starting like sort of right smack
dab in the middle of the Middle Ages
that nobody at that time knew were
Middle Ages so with no further ado we'll
we'll jump in and start talking about
this brilliant medieval thinker
we always begin with one key question
that is probably on many viewers Minds
why should I study this person and some
of Canterbury and it's a very valid
question particularly given how little
attention is paid to him in many
philosophy curricula or classes which is
in part a reflection of the people who
structure it not actually knowing much
about Ansem but be that as it may we'll
get into that later so why is this this
person so important and I've got a few
answers for you first off is that he
once you start reading him and
understand what you're reading you'll
see that he's actually a quite brilliant
thinker he is definitely a philosopher
whatever else he may be of the first
rank so he rates up there with you know
Plato Descartes Thomas Aquinas Hegel all
these people and some definitely
deserves to be placed at the first rank
and that's with a smaller corpus than
many of these other thinkers another
issue that we're going to describe he
made multiple important contributions to
a number of different fields some of
them we could say within philosophy some
of them on the borderlands of philosophy
and some other discipline and some in
other areas so you know what are some of
those contributions
most people know and some if they do it
all because of the so called ontological
argument for the existence of God which
is found in his work the Proust loggia
in Chapter two
or perhaps in chapter two and three or
chapter two two three and four depending
on how you parse it out but that is just
the tiniest little window into what is
going on in his works as a matter of
fact the rest of the Proust Logan and
it's his earlier work the Mona loggia
and explore all these interesting
important topics about you could say the
divine attributes and the relations
between created being and the creative
being that
that he calls God right and he wasn't
really interested in providing an
ontological argument that's that's
terminology that comes up much later on
and we'll get to that in a moment what
were some of the other major
contributions that Ansel made clarifying
the nature of the will and providing a
lot of important discussions that figure
into the question of free will and
determinism some important contributions
in moral theory as well some of them
taken up by people like Thomas Aquinas
right if you if you think about you know
Aquinas as representing one's whole
constellation of thought and an sum is
being part of the Augustinian tradition
you've actually got him wrong you know
when we'll get to that in a little bit
as well he also made some some important
contributions in terms of understanding
time and how you know agency would work
on the part of creatures in relation to
time lots of really interesting stuff
there I'll mention a few other things
that he did and I'll get out so start
doing my show-and-tell
here as well this is a book that we're
going to discuss in a moment the prayers
and meditations of saint saint and some
translated by benedict award his prayers
revolutionized praying you you might say
well how hard could it be to pray well
and some you know has these prayers that
are incredibly you know beautiful and
well crafted rhetoric and their their
doctrinal content is sort of on point
and they also reveal a sort of
metaphysics and morality lying behind
them
that's latent in there and some
interesting explanations of his moral
theory actually happened in the course
of these prayers there dramatical
content is is incredibly important to
and again revolutionize the way that
people thought about praying and some is
somebody who will you know have these
intercession airy prayers talking
particulars Saints and bring them up as
models and sometimes go so far as to
boldly say hey you were kind of a
schmuck in your time and you got
Redemption can you help me out here
that's roughly paraphrasing so that's
another interesting thing as well if you
want to understand other medieval
thinkers those coming after Ansem you
have to read an some SCOTUS uses this
this you know notion that Ansem has of
the two wills but it's not just
Franciscan thinkers Thomas Aquinas
quotes and some quite extensively his
you know views on truth for example are
heavily indebted to Anselm's dialogue on
truth a lot of people don't know this
sort of thing because they don't read
enough thomas or they read it with the
wrong frame of mind and they they can't
see that that you know he was somebody
who was considered very important to
engage with later thinkers you know an
some kind of drops out of view as do
many of the medieval 's during the early
modern period because there's this
reaction against you know moribund
scholasticism and then 19th century
thinkers also tended to discount the
middle ages as well or they're mostly
focused on an some for you know his
ideas about either in in philosophy the
ontological argument or in theology the
argument about why we had to have an
atonement right why did why did God
become man to use one of his most famous
treatises but in the twentieth century
people rediscovered and some in large
part because of the availability of
translations and there's a booming you
know you could say cottage industry in
work on Ansem there's a Institute for
Saint Anselm studies at Saint Anselm
College where I've actually done a
research in resident researcher two
different years I've given the Saint
Anselm lecture there so clearly there's
a community out there engaging with with
Ansem another thing that I would say too
is that there's a certain
to his thought that provides a sort of
attractiveness to it when it's properly
understood there's quite a few people
that get turned off on an some but they
get turned off less because of an some
and his texts and more because of you
know sort of scandals or roadblocks or
blinders that they're bringing to it so
that they read it as being something
other than it is you know a lot of
people approach the you know cur Deus
homo why God became man with the the
notion that Oh Ansem has this terrible
notion of the atonement it's so cruel
and and futile and stuff like that and
if you actually read the text that's not
quite quite the case so there's there's
a lot of interesting reasons why you
might want to study and some I want to
say one thing too as something I haven't
said in previous ones just about
medieval philosophy in general if your
goal is to study philosophy as sort of a
long tradition and field and we're
talking about Western philosophy here
because Eastern philosophy or non
Western philosophy they they have all
their own traditions as well many of
them quite you know vast all of them I
would say worth reading coming back to
the Western medieval philosophy you
can't say that you actually have done a
good survey of the history of philosophy
if you haven't studied quite a few
medieval philosophers there's a tendency
to skip over them so I could do some
ancient and then you know maybe we'll
talk about you know proofs or God's
existence or we'll read a little bit of
Augustine boom now we're done and we're
up to Hobbes and Descartes or maybe
Machiavelli and bacon before them and
we're into the modern period the
medievals didn't know themselves as
medievals as I mentioned they thought of
themselves as continued errs of the
ancient project but now within a a new
you know sort of theologically affected
or infused
framework so it's it's very important to
read them if you actually want to be
well-read in the history of philosophy
and Ansem is somebody who
can't afford to leave out if you're
going to study medieval philosophy in a
serious way
another question that comes up and which
will be aided by some of these texts
that I have here for show-and-tell are
sort of practical questions about well
what texts and translations of and some
should I be using and of course what I'm
going to stay here only applies to
English stuff there's German French
Italian all sorts of translations of
Ansem and I've looked at some of them
but I can't remember about them and I
don't have them for you to look at you
know to say anything about so there
there are some older versions floating
around for example you know st. Anselm's
Proust loggia and where you this is
actually where I cut my teeth on an some
I'm having the English and Latin on
facing pages this was kind of a standard
text for medieval philosophy classes
it's nice to have because I I got into
Ansem for you know doing some practice
in reading Latin then that's what got me
you know hooked on on him Charlesworth
not the best translator this has been
been superseded at this point there's
also some readily available texts out
there in PDF form that were translated
by Herbert Richardson and Jasper Hopkins
as a joint project and then made
available very generously by Hopkins on
his website they've been out there for a
long time on the internet just type it
in there they're there by the Latin
names of the treatises so instead of on
truth it'll be Daivari tatay and those
are not bad those are those are decent
translations there's also you know
recent things like the Oxford world
classics
this is translated by Brian Davies and
Gillian Evans and you know this is not
bad it's at points I find myself saying
yeah this has been rather influenced by
analytic philosophy a problem as well
you can find with some of the
Blackfriars translations of thomas
aquinas those texts where you know say
Anthony Kenny did the trans
and on some of it you're like yeah okay
this is a little bit skewed and then you
know what I would say you know as far as
translators of and some go and the
present your best bet is actually Thomas
Williams more recent
well this one's probably not so much
he has translated a whole bunch of
things with Hackett publishing Williams
is a far as translations goes i I really
like his translations I think that he is
quite close to the the text without
losing too much of its its flavor and
the distinctions that Ansem wants to
make so so I like Williams work quite a
bit and you can find not just the Manalo
Jian and Prost Lodge in but but pretty
much all of an Psalms treatises I
believe at this point translated by
Williams I'm not actually the best
person to ask about the ex I read an
some in the latin and i should mention a
little bit about that so there there are
you know there are the the versions put
together by a Benedictine monk FS
schmidt years and years back six volumes
of and some all of his works including
his correspondence in latin and they're
out there on the internet floating
around in PDF form you can find them
somewhere i use it in that way because I
don't I can't go to a library where they
actually have and some stuff quite slow
so readily in the Latin but you know I I
always consult other people's
translations as well so if you're
reading it in translation you might I
would say definitely get Williams and
then you might want to compare and
contrast with some of the other
translators for some of the other works
you have say Benedict award translating
the prayers and meditations that's
pretty much the standard edition she
also has a translation of the prose
loggia in here as well so you could use
that for comparison sake there are these
three volumes right and some
letters translated by Walter freulich
very good although occasionally you know
what I'm looking at at the Latin I'll be
like well that's an interesting
translation choice but he's not gonna
really lead you astray I do believe that
there is a new set of translations of an
Psalms letters in the works but I don't
know that it's actually been published
yet and that will eventually I suppose
supersede critics translations after a
while it's gonna it takes a while for
these sort of things to catch on so
that's that's you know some stuff about
the the editions and translations
there's their secondary work out there
on and some that I think you might find
helpful you know
Southern's work on an some is older but
very reliable and that would be our w
southern the great medievalist who also
played in a very important role in
bringing Ansem back into the forefront
of medieval studies you know somebody
who I look up to a lot Katherine Rogers
she has several books out on and so I'm
including a fairly recent one on Anselm
and freedom that I find quite good not
everybody likes you know her stuff
because of course you know any any
scholarship thing people don't always
agree on it you can also find things
like a Cambridge companion to and some
some of the essays in that are quite
good some of them as an Anselm scholar I
read them they're like yeah kind of off
base but you know there's there's plenty
of secondary literature out there if
that's helpful for you you know I always
generally recommend and I'm looking over
on the shelf I'm not going to try to
reach it friedrich cobblestones chapter
on Anselm
not bad I I don't think he really had a
great appreciation for for him the way
that he did for some of the other
thinkers but he's not gonna lead you
astray so I would avoid sort of big
picture histories of philosophy most of
their chapters at Anselm tend to you
know frame him just in terms of the
ontological argument
the cur Deus homo argument for the
Incarnation and they leave out
everything else so those those are not
particularly helpful you want to
approach and some in a kind of holistic
way I would say his corpus is fairly
manageable there are two other things
that I wanted to bring up as well if you
want to get serious about an some
studies it's good to have the life of
st. Anselm because this is by his his
quote one of his closest friends and his
biographer the monk Adler again Latin on
one side English on the other so if you
want to work on your Latin ya de Mer
also wrote a history of Britain that
includes some stuff about and some but
but you know much broader in scope as
well this is one that hasn't been
translated although I'm actually working
on translations of some of the texts in
here have done for years they've just
been kind of kind of busy and this is
the this is put out by at that Schmidt
and RW southern this is the memorials of
st. Anselm these are treaty sees that
Anselm did did most likely write or
contribute to that didn't make it into
like the the official treatises right so
we've got the de homonymous more ebooks
on human you know mores which is a sort
of reconstruction out of the day similar
to Danube us another work that that is
attributed to an some that circulated
around a lot in the Middle Ages we have
the dicta on sell me stuff that an Psalm
is supposed to have said and not just
sort of like offhand remarks like oh you
know King looks kind of irritated with
me today
more like stuff that he was actually
teaching to other people we have the de
miraculous by Alexander and we we have a
few other things like you know the de
Banta to Denis by Yad mer and then then
some some fragments so it's pretty cool
stuff but you got to be able to read
Latin in order to get anything out of
that so that's probably enough about
about the
texts themselves
so I
all of that has been said one one
question that people always ask as well
as okay so where should I start and then
you know what book should I begin with
and where should I go after that and I
would say there's there's really two to
productive ways you could go one is to
read the treaty sees in somewhat of a
chronological order the other way would
be you could start by by heading in with
the prayers and meditations and the
Prost lo Jian so you know we could call
that the the more structured an analytic
way or the more you know diving into the
relationship with with you know God and
the divine and and other people who
share in that sort of interest in
inquiry path so let's talk about the
first one first because that's that's
probably the one most people are going
to take you could start with the prosto
Jian if you wanted to I think a lot of
people starting with the pro slow Jia
and are gonna be you know a little bit
taken aback at at the but what the hell
is this because it's not written in the
way that a philosophical treatise
typically is it is literally a pro slow
Jian someone talking with you know God
and to lesser degree with his soul as
sort of a figure and trying to
understand what God is how God is you
might say and so that that could be a
little off-putting to some people and I
would actually suggest starting with the
first book that that Ansem writes the
Mona lo Jian which is a little bit
longer and the argumentation is a little
less abbreviated in there and the two
works have a very close connection with
each other he wrote the Mona Logie in
first and we'll talk about that the
conditions under which he wrote in just
a little bit essentially it's a teaching
tool for his monks and then he decided
you know this is really kind of long and
complicated could I do could I do better
could I come up with one argument one
argumentum
continuous line of thought that would
actually accomplish everything that was
done in the Mona Logie and he says yes
and that was the Proust low Jian so
their companion pieces you don't want to
read the pro slogan without reading the
Mona loggia so you know depending on
which one you're gonna read I would say
the Mona Logie on first but if you want
to read the pro slogan that's fine and
then where do you go after that
so then Anselm wrote after that not not
too far off in time
three treatises that are he said these
are all written at different times but
they form a kind of trilogy or triptych
and that would be the on truth of de
Vera taught a the on freedom of choice
the de Libertad a Arbit three and the on
the fall of the devil de caso de moly
right and they're all concerned with
questions of like you know the first one
says on truth what are the different
modes of truth and some think that truth
isn't just something in propositions or
in the mind in relation to reality it's
also there in action and the will and
it's also built into the fabric of the
universe so he moves from there into
considerations of the will itself and
free choice and then the de caso do you
bully you might say I don't want to get
into that that's you know too much
theology or mythology
well you'd really be screwing yourself
if you were gonna say I'm not gonna read
that because it's about you know this
this legendary devil because Anselm is
exploring questions like how could the
devil actually fall if he was created
all good and it's a good god so if you
know we got an interest in the problem
of evil or you know human free choice
because it's also applying to that you
better read the de caso de bully and
there's a progressive development of the
understanding not only of truth but also
of the way the will is structured
through those pieces there is a fourth
dialogue I should mention that those
those three are all dialogues between a
teacher and a student there's a fourth
one called the de Grammatik Oh which is
about the grammarian and
that's useful to read you could maybe
put that off for later or you could
stick that in there if you want to a lot
of good discussions of distinctions
being made there and then from there you
you start to read the more mature
treatises so what do we have in mind
there you don't necessarily have to read
everything that he writes like the
letter on the procession of the Holy
Spirit but you probably do want to read
the Epistle on the incarnation of the
word because that has a lot of
metaphysical and epistemological points
that he's making there and then there's
the cur Deus homo that's got two books
because it's a big work and in a
theological context that's often viewed
as an Psalms most important work but
it's got a lot of philosophical meat to
it as well if you're interested in the
nature of you know justice and injustice
there's some of the work that's being
done in the earlier treatises is really
getting fleshed out in the cur Deus homo
and then in its companion piece the on
the Virgin conception and original sin
the Daquan ketsu that's a very important
work to read as well and like I said the
these themes are getting worked out and
elaborated and within these he starts to
finally develop his full treatment of
the will then we we have another work
that has three three sections to it
that's very important later on the on
the Harmony Day Concordia I'm a harmony
of you know free will with
predestination etc etc etc we usually
just call a fee you know de Concordia
and there a lot of really interesting
stuff going on including you know some
some great discussions of time and how
it fits in with free will that hearken
back to but are not doing exactly the
same thing as earlier discussions in
Augustine and boëthius
so that's you know the bulk of Anselm's
stuff in terms of the treaty
like I mentioned there's there's other
treatises that haven't been translated
in in the memorials now the other path
that you could take is by saying all
right I'm going to instead begin with an
Psalms more devotional we would say
works and if you do that is really quite
a path and you can read these prayers
without you know necessarily believing
in anything theistic you can appreciate
them as a sort of you know dramatic
engagement a sort of dialogue with God
and the Saints and one's own screwed-up
soul and you get a lot of insight into
an sung by it by reading this and the
prosto Gian you know the prosto Gian is
actually intended to be prayed I I'll
mention a few
just something that's kind of funny so I
used to use the pro so Gian as a
devotional work and I may some time in
my future and I remember talking with
Paul Griffiths the the great long stin
Ian scholar among other things and he
said you know I think in previous times
there were probably quite a few people
who actually did use it that way but and
I'm very well-traveled and I know a lot
of theologians and people who are
involved in religious studies you got to
be the only person I know who's actually
using the pro slogan in that way now
that's not quite true because eileen
sweeney actually has a wonderful piece
on praying the pro slogan and I bet that
she does it because she's she's quite a
great person she's another important
Anselm scholar too by the way but that
that's another avenue that you could
take I think if you if you want to go
further with Anselm and really
understand his work sooner or later
you're going to actually have to read
the the letters because they aren't just
stuff like hey I'm in charge as a bishop
here you better knock off your
tomfoolery or anything like that he goes
into some great spiritual counseling
discussions with different schools with
laypeople
he also
explains some of the things that are
going on in his works or some of the
topics to people in particular context
so really well worth worth reading so
those are my suggestions about how to
get yourself started reading and some
like I said two main ways you could go
both of them are gonna have you reading
the pro slowly and early on
as you're approaching and somes work I
think that it's good to bear a number of
things in mind that otherwise might lead
to two factors tripping you up so
understanding and some sort of big
picture projects and the situation that
he was in and something a little bit
about you know medieval intellectual
life can can can be very helpful so what
i'm doing here is providing you with
some context some things to keep in mind
so the first thing to keep in mind is
that and some himself was so he was a
monk he's a Benedictine monk he chose
that lifestyle and you know when you
enter the monastery especially a
Benedictine monastery they have this
this motto aura at labora work and pray
and for Anselm you know he really
entered it for a couple reasons one was
he wanted to do the aura he wanted it to
pray he wanted it to you know connect
with with God more deeply he had done
some stuff he traveled around a bit he'd
had you know some some exposure to a
more worldly life we don't exactly know
what he did but he felt guilty about it
so that's that's part of it he wants to
to understand God better and what a
Benedictine monastery is one of the
places where you could do that he also
chose back in particular because lon
Frank was teaching there and lon Frank
was a former lawyer who became a monk
and then was prior of that monastery it
was a very new monastery the the founder
of it heroin had been a soldier who then
found a monastic vocation had some
monies like I'm establishing this
monastery in back so lon Frank is the
the prior the person was teaching the
other monks or like the
second-in-command underneath the the
abbot and Anselm's like well if I go to
that monastery Vaughn Frank is a really
bright guy I'm not going to be tempted
towards like intellectual pride because
I'll be under
and that'll help me out cuz I know I've
got tendencies towards that at least at
that time as it turns out and some winds
up doing the labora a lot more than he
had originally anticipated LAN Franck
leaves he becomes Archbishop of
Canterbury under William the Conqueror
in part because of his Norman
connections and Ansem is voted in as the
prior which means now he's in charge not
just of like doing his own thing but
teaching the other monks this is part of
why he writes the Treaty sees that he
does we'll get to that in just a moment
after a while when hare Lewin dies they
vote in Ansem as abbot that means a lot
more responsibilities than being just
you know the prior or even being a
regular monk doing doing his thing it
doesn't take all that long after that we
ran some after you know lon Franck dies
and the the archbishopric of Canterbury
is left open for a while where the new
king William Rufus is like I'm putting
Anselm in you know I want to have the
same relationship with him as my dad had
with LAN Franck and he's gonna be kind
of a pushover anyway cuz it's a monk and
he's kind of old and all that they make
him a bishop more or less against his
wishes and that means a lot more
responsibilities so Anselm is not
somebody who has the luxury you know if
we would compare him to st. Thomas
Aquinas later on Aquinas has something
to do all of his you know transcription
for him he is a teacher that's his only
job Anselm doesn't get around to writing
all the things that he'd like to write
as a matter of fact you know on his
deathbed he says you know I there
there's another thing I wish I would
have written because it's gonna take you
all a long time to figure it out about
the nature of the soul so most of his
writings are you could say occasioned in
one way or another so this leads into
something else it's important when you
read his writings to look at the
premises of them he tells you why I
wrote this
work and so the Mona lo Jian why did he
write it down the the monks after his
teaching were just pestering him and
they're like you know the stuff that
you're teaching us is great could you
write it down for us could you put it
into words so we we don't have to like
always be coming to you you know I don't
remember exactly what you said at this
point Pro slogans similar kind of thing
except now he's like yeah that was a
good first try can I can I improve on it
the theological you know but they're
also deeply philosophical treatises on
truth on freedom of choice on the fall
the devil teaching aids ostensibly to
teach the monks how to understand
Scripture but really how to understand
all sorts of things that are spurred by
by thinking about scripture you know
some of the the other things like on you
know the incarnation of the word you
know on the procession of the Holy
Spirit those things are those things are
occasion because somebody else is like
hey we need we need some writing on this
and so there's you know Anselm is trying
to get what he can done he spends a lot
of time you know like I noted writing
letters because he's a busy guy and the
letters are really actually quite quite
important quite great but he doesn't
always get to do what he would prefer to
do he's not some university professor
who teaches one or two classes you know
and that has grad students to do a lot
of his work for him he is somebody who
has a lot lot on his plate if you read
the letters hole man there is so much
going on in England and France and the
whole of Christendom at the time you
know he's doing things like counseling
people about whether to go on crusade or
not Anselm's not a fan of that too you
know providing some some insight about
you know marriage counseling consoling
you know monks and nuns dealing with the
fact that you've got this displacement
of the anglo-saxon previous nobility by
the Norman nobility trying to institute
ecclesiastical reforms staying on top of
the day to day stuff of running a
diocese a busy guy so that's really
important
what else is important about his
situation he is a monk and the monks we
often think of them as these sort of
otherworldly figures all you got to do
is read a little bit of monastic
literature to realize no they're they're
human beings and they're trying to live
a human life
in community together they also have
libraries and some is somebody who is
very well-read and we have some
evidences of that from the letters
doesn't show up in his writing he's not
somebody who quotes or sites or says
this person is an authority we're gonna
get to that in a moment
he's very unusual in that way but he's
read just about everything that can be
read at that time so he is he's not just
read Christian authors who are available
like Augustine or locked-on see us or
boëthius or people like that he's also
read what's available of pagan
literature which includes Seneca which
includes Cicero which includes some
extracts from Plato or Aristotle not a
lot but but some and he's you know these
are things that the monks have in their
their libraries so that that's important
to keep in mind as well
philosophy had a wider range you could
say in terms of what it encompassed so
you know Anselm is definitely a
Christian philosopher there wasn't a
rigid division as it happens later
between you know this is philosophy this
died this is theology on this side they
kind of inter penetrated each other he
doesn't actually call his work
philosophy he doesn't worry about that
term because he's doing thought as a
matter of fact somebody like a teenager
soul would say that really Anselm is not
doing philosophy or theology as such
he's doing something that we might call
Christian gnosis you know there's a lot
of different ways of looking at this
well I have some writing on that myself
which I'll link to in the video
description below some things that I
wrote years back which hopefully are
still available online
and film's central motive or motif is he
that feed a squadron's intellect Amit
shows up in the pro slow Gian which he
wanted actually to be called Phoenix
quadrants intellect him what does that
mean faith seeking understanding now you
might say although he's an apologist
he's already got everything figured out
and now he's just trying to arrange it
in some sort of philosophical or
rational manner no not at all the case
you start from believing something this
is an Augustinian motif as well this
also comes up in the Septuagint and
volga translations of isaiah unless you
believe you will not understand right
you begin from some sort of faith
perspective and commitment and you say
what the hell is this about what's going
on here
then you use the rational faculties
given to us by the divine as part of
human nature to figure that out so
that's why you know he could say that on
truth or on the fall the devil are you
know treatises to help people understand
scripture because scripture itself is
not always clear and is you know very
productive of interesting ideas but
you've got to clarify those ideas along
the way an an some will go so far as to
say hey if you're reading scripture and
it says it says something that's like
totally it seems totally off-base you're
probably reading scripture wrong
there's probably got to be another way
of parsing out what's being said and you
use your rational mind in order to do
that so there's a dialectic between
faith and reason going on in Ansem
you've got to keep that in mind don't
try to push him off just to become a
rationalist don't try to push him off on
the other side and just become a
speediest
because if you do you lose Ansem and
you're not you're not actually reading
the text faithfully or carefully he is a
very highly original thinker he is
working within a tradition but like I
mentioned doesn't cite the people that
he's referring to so sometimes it could
be good to have read some augustine or
some boethius beliefs
is also very important or some of those
earlier pagan authors to write the whole
notion of that then which nothing
greater can be thought shows up in some
some stoic writings by the way there's
actually an article out there about that
which I don't remember who wrote it but
I remember coming across it in my
researches an Psalm is doing his thing
and he unlike almost everybody else he
has enough confidence he doesn't have to
quote everybody else to back him up he
thinks that the rational argumentation
can sort of stand on its own that's
probably enough about about things to
keep in mind as you're reading him
I also do have some brief advice that's
based on the format or structure of his
works and a lot of this is more or less
don't screw yourself up by expecting
something to be what it isn't so let's
start with that if you're used to
reading other medieval treatises
particularly later things you know like
where there's that question-answer sort
of format like you know Thomas Aquinas
or also later scholastics Anselm is not
doing cuestiones de patata right he's
not doing that sort of format that
happens later on with scholasticism
Anselm has got his own sort of genres
and it differs from text to text he's
got some dialogues you know all those
three well for you know if you count the
day grammatical early ones and then the
day can cap to on the virgin birth later
on as a dialogue no that's not a
dialogue sorry the the cur Deus homo is
a dialogue right so you know he's using
the dialogue form which you might
remember from like say Plato but it's
not a platonic dialogue it's a different
kind of dialogues probably closer to
those of Augustine or some of the other
later Christian thinkers but then the
pro slow Gian is like a whole different
kind of thing that's supposed to be unum
argumentum a single argument that
encompasses all of this stuff and the
manalo Jim and as a you know context to
more agreement or may a framework of
arguments a fabric of arguments you have
to be okay with Ansem using the format
that he does and you also have to be
okay with him not answering every single
question he's not writing books to be
comprehensive
he's usually dealing with one you know
set of issues and he'll say by the way
this is another issue but we'll talk
about that at another time and sometimes
he doesn't talk about it right so that's
just part of the structure of his work
you you definitely need to read and pay
attention to
the introductions or prologues of his
works as well because that that gives
you some idea about how you're supposed
to read it so that's important too and
the you know there's two other things I
would say one is that his work is
incredibly dialogical or dialectical
it's it's always involving a sort of
back and forth and back and forth and
you zero in and clarify things it's not
set up to be like you know argument
argument argument you know there's a lot
of sort of you know like lingering with
the argument so that you can actually
fully understand it he's not he's not
one of these argument bros who's like
here's my premises must lead inevitably
to this conclusion no he's coming kind
of lead you there right there's a lot of
openness to his work that you want to
take account of the other thing I'll say
too is Ansem was in you know very widely
known as somebody who taught by using
likenesses similar to Denis similar to
Denis in Latin right a likeness is a
kind of analogy he was incredibly good
at coming up with these on the spot for
his students you got to be careful with
any sort of analogy in thinking that
there's a one-to-one mapping for things
right Anselm's not a dummy so he doesn't
think that when he gives some sort of
likeness that it's exactly like this
right so you know you've got to be
attentive to that and the Anselm gives
you some clues to that in his own work
so those are some some bits of advice
that are derived from the the structure
itself of his work
as I get to the end of these videos I
usually like to bring up some some
problems or issues that people have
raised with and some or whoever we're
working on that I think are actually
either blind alleys or sort of called
the sacks or distractions that you don't
need to worry about so much you can get
into them later it's not as if they're
totally without merit but they're
they're really not the sort of thing
that a beginner has to like figure out
before they're going to start studying
somebody and you may actually get into
them and realize that they are kind of
kind of you know a waste of time and
based on bad research which is the case
for most of them so let's start off by
talking about the ontological argument
right and some very few people know him
for more than the ontological argument
when they encounter them in a philosophy
class it's usually just Proust law jiàn
- or maybe pro slogan two through four
they don't bother to read the prologue
they don't bother to read the rest of it
they don't read the chapter one which is
incredibly incredibly important and some
did not think of what he was doing as an
ontological argument for God's existence
that terminology is coming later on that
classification with German idealism with
somebody like Hunt right and in you know
the critique of Pure Reason Kant shows
himself to not really understand the
ontological argument although he thinks
all the other arguments are based on
that he did in fact have some some
lectures on the philosophy of religion
where he where he shows he can in fact
you know talk about an some as such
without totally distorting what he's
doing
there's also earlier treatments of the
argument for example Thomas Aquinas in
Summa contra Gentilly talks about the
argument as such in the Summa Theologica
or TL ogi depending on you know how you
render it early on in that chat you know
in prima pars question - he does talk
about something kind of like an Psalms
argument but not exactly an
Holmes argument in the commentary on the
Psalms he actually says by the way
something people don't generally read
and Soames is right
Dave's essay is is something that that
you know the predicate is contained in
the subject which isn't actually what
Anselm says anyway but but it shows that
Thomas is more attentive to what's going
on you don't need to worry about the
ontological argument to read the Proust
loggia because the Proust low Jian is
nesting what people want to call the
ontological argument within the UNAM
argumentum the single argument that
isn't just supposed to prove that God
exists but also that God is the you know
the supreme good that all other goods
need and everything else we believe
about God so if you want to you know
study and pay attention to the rest of
the text is what I'm saying and and
don't just say well I got a you know
focused on the pro SLO GN because that's
where the most important stuff happens
no it's it's all across his his corpus
so this is fascination with a construct
of just a tiny portion of an somewhere
as I said like this tiny little window
that you're looking in on not a very
productive way of approaching him but it
is the way many people have another
thing that you don't want to do is try
to shoehorn and stone and his thought
into somebody else's classification
system this is a big problem not only
for analytic philosophers in the present
and also for you know modern
philosophers you know like a contour or
also Hegel whose receptive to an some
you know it's all about these proofs and
stuff like that it's a big problem for
Thomas as well because there's like you
know this is we're gonna talk about this
in another video there are Thomas who
are very attentive to Thomas Aquinas is
own method and the spirit of his works I
have no beef with them and then there
are people who are like the most
doctrinaire scholastics everything has a
neat little category you know and we do
everything in syllogisms and that's
that's not even remotely tal mystic but
they build themselves as Thomas
they usually totally misunderstand
and psalms work and they don't even
realize that ant that Thomas makes so
many references to an some that he drew
this like theory of truth half way from
Aristotle half way from not Augustine
and so and we could go on and on and on
with it with examples like that so you
don't want to try to shoehorn you know
an Solomon said oh he's he's one of
those Augustinians and everything can be
divided into Aristotelian and Platon
Asst Aquinas is an Aristotelian and
somewhat like all these other people
before him as a Plata stats [ __ ]
that that's the worst sort of lazy
history of philosophy that there is out
there but if you buy into that or you
listen to the people that say that
you're gonna be putting blinders on you
want to read things on their own you
know judge them on their own merits
you want to see what's actually there in
the text and some is somewhat
Augustinian but he's a very different
kind of Augustinian than say Bonaventure
or you know Augustine himself or any of
these other people so it's really
important that you don't do that
another blinder that people put on is
they're like I need to distinguish the
philosophy from the theology you know
cuz because he's a religious thinker and
religious people are like you know
religiously committed and they they're
you know turning their minds off you
know it's studying ants on that that led
me to realize that Christian thinkers
could in fact have something on the ball
that they could be quite brilliant so
that you know that that's me
that's my experience if you want to know
about that maybe you want to watch my
video on how I became an anthem scholar
because that's not something I would
have ever thought philosophy and
religion interpenetrate and it's it's a
you know the decision to like cut them
neatly down the line that's not a very
good philosophical or a very good
theological decision because it doesn't
match what we know about the history of
Western thought an Psalm is if you're
gonna say that there are people out
there who are sort of you know committed
religious feed Asma they just want to
turn the turn
the brain off there are some like that
and some is at the other extreme so if
you approach him in that way you're
you're screwing yourself up from the
beginning
Ansem can be read by somebody who's an
atheist and if the person is open-minded
and intelligent enough to follow along
an Psalms thought they can get quite a
lot out of it if they're not well then
then you know that's so much the worse
for them so those are the things that
you want to like you know maybe put to
the side while you're reading an some if
you're gonna study him and you want it
to be productive
I always like to end these with some
final thoughts and so first off I'm
going to say this the same message that
I give in most of my videos in this
series that if you are deciding to do
for yourself you're already engaged in
the process of self-directed study in
philosophy that's great
and I congratulate you on whatever
success you've achieved and I hope for
greater success in that and the measure
of that is how well you're able to
understand and appreciate the various
thinkers and texts and movements and
ideas that you're engaging with it's not
really just about like checking things
off on a list it's more like
intellectually forming yourself and
making room inside
what hopefully is a vast you know space
in your mind for these these people and
thinkers to inhabit and sometimes they
might be arguing with each other and
that that's okay that's the history of
philosophy so if you're doing that great
and everybody does that to certain
degrees and everybody does that you know
to in the the space and time that they
have available so if you're not able to
do it as much as you'd like it's better
to do some than not to do it or better
to do more than to do less and film is
somebody who if you if you approach his
text in a I won't say the right way
because there's multiple right ways of
approaching his text but if you approach
it in a productive manner open to
learning from him I can tell you from
experience it's going to be a rich rich
yield on your part and you may be
surprised by how much you come to like
what you're you're thinking about
there's something almost seductive but
in Psalms writings I mean again who
would a knew that some some kid who you
know grew up here in in Wisconsin when
in the army it was very martially
oriented left the church at sixteen
thought that that Christian thought was
all kind of you know doctrinaire
nonsense that I would have been sucked
into becoming by the you know
midpoint of my graduate school somebody
who is going to focus a lot of his
career on st. Anselm of all things right
well that's that's let's do to me and
more due to an some so I think you're
gonna find him very rewarding it's not
something that you're going to realize
all at once hopefully he'll become an
interlocutor that likes some of the
other great people Plato Aristotle
Cicero you know going on further and
further that will be with you talking at
you and you know suggesting ideas for
the rest of your life as he is for me
surprise surprise so that's all I really
have to say and I hope that you find
this useful and that you do study and
some and some of the earlier medieval
thinkers and later medieval thinkers
you